[Musique]
après paypal space x et tesla est le
must s'est attaqué au réseau social
twitter
s'est acheté twitter pour 44 milliards
d'euros avec ce rachat l'homme le plus
riche de la planète signe un coup
d'éclat j'espère que même les pires
détracteurs resteront sur twitter c'est
ce que signifie la liberté d'expression
un message clair destiné à tous les
réfractaires des libertés d'opinion et
aux adeptes de la censure mais est ce
que dit toutes les expressions doivent
pouvoir s'exprimer sur twitter on sait
au delà de son esprit très libertaires
et le noise qui a toujours eu les
conditions les plus folles
vers la planète mars et un lance flamme
en cas d' attaque de zombies humaine
connecter nos cerveaux à des ordinateurs
rien que par la pensée ces fantasmes
sont sans limites alors tyrannique ou
polies et secrets cachés ce soir on vous
dit tout sur la face cachée des l'odm
est
la face cachée des laids meuf qui serait
l'homme le plus riche du monde devant
alors farfelues apparemment il est quand
même alors faut savoir que ce garçon
contrairement à ses camarades
milliardaire au millionnaire n'a ni
raison principale ni maison de campagne
il absolument rien à part des actions et
il s'est acheté une seule chose c'était
un petit avion un gulfstream 550 d'une
valeur de 65 millions d'euros hors
options c'est comme les voitures parler
des choses et ils dormiraient dedans et
quand il va dans ses usines tesla il
dort jamais l'hôtel pour pas dépenser
l'argent il dort dans l' usine j'ai des
copains illico en plus en plus il ya des
oursins dans les poches de mai qui pèse
des milliards de dollars il sort pas un
kopeck c'est comment s'attendre comme ça
qui les a gagné le mans legend et des
riches je souris sont radins leriche
herrada et oui c'est un paradis ils sont
intelligents soit et je regarderai pas
intelligent enfin je sais pas tu peux
t'en remets à décanter pas tu peux te
paye un lit en fait faut arrêter c'est
pas intelligent alors
la face cachée des laids mais déjà on va
revenir sur twitter apparemment
l'affairé était bien engagée et puis là
ce matin patatras gil ben oui c'est
extrêmement compliqué parce que les
accusations qu'il porte se réfère aux
autres accusations qu'il a toujours
portées contre ses anciens accusés il y
avait eu paypal lui il a passé une
enfance sur fond de violences en afrique
du sud il avait reconnu lui même avoir
des comportements et des très grands os
des très grands bas il est bipolaire et
là la violence qu'il a utilisée contre
les actionnaires de twitter leur fait
dire finalement non seulement vous nous
insulter après avoir conclu un accord
mais est ce que c'est bien raisonnable
de vous confier d'autres entreprises et
à chaque fois il ya ça lui passe en
force pour le moment tout lui réussit
mais là on se demande si ça va pas être
le premier coup d'arrêt s'est pas encore
complètement raté mais il ya néanmoins
des embûches sur son prix avait par
contre a pas le droit de s'exprimer
selon sur l'entreprise ni les salariés
avant de l'avoir racheté mes frères ce
concept a pris ce qu'il a fracassé cause
émergents donc c'est compliqué alors
deuxième question quel est l'intérêt de
racheter twitter pour huit agents qui
compte le sortir de la bourse autrement
dit c'est comme si vous mettez 44
milliards et que vous allez la valeur
boursière donc ses 44 bd à poubelles oui
c'est un petit peu dommage
il est dérangé par twitter dans sa
version actuelle ici rachète twitter il
y aurait des changements concrets sur la
plateforme pour les utilisateurs par
exemple on pourra modifier un tweet
après sa publication mais le gros
changement c'est surtout la liberté
d'expression il veut permettre aux gens
de s'exprimer librement et donc ce
serait la fin des censures des comptes
pour des raisons parfois hasardeuse mais
cet accord à part quelques grands
comptes
genre donald trump sur twitter accusés
on a vu les tombereaux dit merde
comprend tous les jours sur la tête on
en a ici des gens si ça fait sucrer non
content cette année mais en fait je
pense que vous voyez le problème à
l'envers excuse moi c'est très grave ce
que tu dis parce que en vrai c'est ce
qui doit se passer l'envers c'est à dire
que les gens qui sont sur les réseaux
sociaux aujourd'hui twitter c'est le
pire réseau social qui existe c'est pas
une liberté d'expression c'est un
ramassis de haine on demande justement à
ce qui est des sanctions qui sont là
maintenant beaucoup plus rapidement on
demande à ce que ce soit fait plus vite
il n'y a pas de plateforme peut pas
appeler au sos à l'eau s'il vous plaît
aidez moi on peut rien faire lui il
arrive de racheter twitter il dit en
plus alors moi je vais les laisser
libres encore plus que ce que c'est mais
à lomé est pas due à l'eau c'est très
dangereux est très très dangereux il est
dangereux alors éligibles à une info
c'est qu'en fait pourquoi j'ai dit la
vérité vous avez tout dit vous avez cité
donald trump et oui en fait c'est une
opération politique
il roule avec trump sans le dire il
n'est pas soutien officiel mais
officieux et ultralibéral libéral
libertariens quand ils me regardent et
donc en fait trump qui a été beaucoup
critiquée sur les réseaux grâce à lui va
pouvoir aller à fond sur twitter et
arrive à 10 il a dit qu'il voulait
rester sur tout ce qui est son réseau à
lui mais là apparemment lalala 30 pouces
h une politique à la mise en place et
qu'en fait comme on est à mi mandat
exact en amérique en récupérant twitter
il peut fracassé le gouvernement en
place et surtout être en place pour le
pro à la prochaine élection en
terrassant politi en deux ans la voilà
ce qu'est ce qui est fou c'est qui dit
qu'il veut aucune limite même pas de
titre assiste enfin il régla liberté
d'expression d'agréable à même sauf
qu'il ya un internaute qui s'est amusé à
calculer c'est justement ces voyages en
jet privé ce que ça pouvait coûter à la
planète eh bien il a censuré donc voilà
c'est fait ce que je fais mais parce que
doit passer le principe des sept
principes
déchire parce que ce mec a tout réussi
il a vendu paypal il a créé space x et
tesla c'est à l'école vous il ya
derrière il ya quand même beaucoup de
dégâts mais ne peuvent pas indiqué le
premier ministre canadien il avait dit
vous êtes vite leur île sans doute
quelqu'un qui n'a pas de limites mais
c'est comme amazon qui aura certes un
emploi ou tout ça je dis aujourd'hui
tous eu malheureusement il ya des choses
des dommages collatéraux mais ça c'est
un autre débat je pense que s'il va
aujourd'hui c'est qu'il est sûre du coup
et qui va encore faire exploser les
compteurs fin non je crois que ça a
besoin de pouvoir effectivement il a
raison gilles il ya certainement autre
chose parce que je pense qu'il n'a pas
besoin de twitter dans son dans son
business parce qu'il en a suffisamment
donc là on est dans au delà parce que
c'est un tel niveau mais au delà voilà
et que et que quand on arrive à ce
niveau là justement vous doivent je peux
comprendre qu'il doit y avoir un jour
vous allez relever qu'il a connu à avoir
un syndrome d'asperger
voilà idée hein c'est un impératif et je
suis pour expliquer un peu cessé sa
crise de ses crises de colère oui toute
petite parenthèse culturelle moi il me
fait vraiment penser à hobart dukes vous
savez ce milliardaire de l'année
fatigue d'un
mini mini qui se paie plus les honte
parce que il n'est pas voilà et c'est
lui qui a créé la panam dubié compagnie
américaine de aérienne à midi ensemble
et
par leonardo dicaprio n'a pu dénombrer
tu t'en avais encore premier aviator
aviez seulement il est le premier à
avoir investi dans le temps dans
l'aérospatiale en quelque sorte omar
tout ce qui l'a ramené il a fini
complètement fou vous le dit et on sait
très bien ici que notre personnage est
en train de devenir beaucoup et en
parlant d'une addition avec son bal en
bal en aspiration elon musk un aurait
inspiré la nouvelle version de iron man
c'est les films de super héros le tony
stark un peu flamboyant d'ailleurs les
finales
absolument tom cruise il allait
remplacer ce qui va remplacer comment il
s'appelle normalement qui seront
donnés junior hexagonal le rôle d'iron
l'euro passait très bien être n'est ce
pas on a vu quelques images d'ailleurs
qui sont passés soit né à vélo semble
pas correspondre à moins que vous savez
combien il poserait en fait 304
milliards de dollars le pied total
269 milliards il est marié il a eu accès
à la bd
alors vous avez vu dans le procès ne
pourrait pas d ailleurs solidaires ces
passionnés que c'est un appel aux images
mais en fait il ya une caméra de
surveillance qui les a surpris les deux
avec un beurre et alors où on voit des
images scanner peut aller y aller un peu
oui voilà à l'ère jobs voulait faire
témoigner parce qu'il souffre oui ils
ont absolument alors il sa dernière
lubie il voudrait racheter coca cola
sabots mais l'image est ingénieur vous
êtes fous dans le service qui voulait
faire avec pas écopé comme ces cas là
pourquoi apple coca cola parce que alors
une île et à la feuille de coca la
feuille de coca qui dit crise il
voudrait mettre de la cocaïne le thème
ouais donc une icône un peu cintrée
jianhua 14 il a défié à wiesen
alors il a fait un truc que j'ai aps -
moi aimer c'est qu'il a fait un tube
carrément grosso fog samedi dernier
contre bill gates en montrant une photo
de bill gate et en montrant un homme
enceint en disant si vous avez des
problèmes d'érection enfin bon nous
voilà donc au volant sont donc urbania
locateur moi je veux bien alors il est
l'homme le huitième le plus suivi du
monde sur twitter un peu corrélés au ban
après trump wallaby les plus huppés
irlande angleterre puis début sur
twitter il était viré il était minuit
dit est il d'accord alors on sait que il
a été accusé de harcèlement aussi fils
je ne savais absolument évident dans
tesla et dans ce pays qu ils étaient les
actions de harcèlement et s'il aurait
permis justement de ce que disait daniel
de propager un peu d'ambiance sexistes
au sein de l'entreprise c'était assez
controversé il pourrait bien prendre une
cuite sur la tête quand même si
c'est vrai qu'il n'est pas très
rassurant mais on parlait de martin7
j'adore et a priori dans le rôle ça
sinon je serais pour la photo non mais
je te parle de 2 to set tu vois qu'on
trop en fait quand tu veux trop trop
trop trop quand à 7,7 cette soif de
vouloir du pouvoir c'est karl henry tu
deviens dangereux et tout pour lui j'ai
attendu x contrôlé par eni a perdu ses
intérêts comme lui un bon jour je vous
dire si je me perds franchement avec les
jours
[Applaudissements]